the term human level performance is
sometimes use casually in research
articles but let me show you how we can
define a little bit more precisely and
in particular use the definition that
the phrase human level performance that
is most useful for helping you drive
progress in your machine learning
project so remember from our last video
that one of the uses of this race human
level error is that it gives us a way of
estimating Bayes error what is the best
possible error any function could either
now or in the future ever ever achieve
so bearing that in mind let's look at a
medical innovation classification
example let's say that you want to look
at a radiology image like this and make
a diagnosis classification decision and
suppose that a typical human untrained
human achieves 3% around estas a typical
doctor may be a typical radiologist
doctor achieves 1% error an experienced
doctor does even better at 0.7 percent
error and a team of experienced doctors
that is to get a team of experienced
doctors and them all look at the image
and discuss and debate the image
together their consensus opinion
achieves 0.5% error so the question I
want to pose to you is how should you
define human level error is human level
error represent one percent point seven
percent or point five percent feel free
to pause this video to think about it if
you wish and to answer that question I
would urge you to bear in mind that one
of the most useful ways to think of
human error is as a proxy or an estimate
for Bayes error so please feel free to
pause this video to think about it for a
while if you wish but just how I would
define human level error which is if you
want a proxy or an estimate for Bayes
error then given that a team of
experienced doctors discussing and
debating can achieve 0.5 percent error
we know that Bayes error is less than
equal to 0.5 percent
because some system team of this doctors
can achieve 0.5% error so by definition
the theoretically optimal error has
gotta be 0.5% or lower
we don't know how much better it is
maybe there's a even larger team of even
more experienced doctors Academy's
inventor so maybe it's even more better
than 0.5% but we know the also error
cannot be higher than 0.5% so what I
would do in this setting is use open't
5% as our estimate for Bayes error so I
would define human level performance as
0.5% at least if you're hoping to use
human level error in the analysis of
bias and variance as we saw in the last
video now for the purpose of publishing
a research paper or for the purpose of
deploying a system maybe there's a
different definition of human level
error that you can use which is so long
as you surpass the performance of a
typical doctor that seems like maybe a
very useful result to accomplish and
maybe surpassing a single radiologist a
single doctors performance might mean
the system is good enough to deploy in
some contexts
so maybe the takeaway from this is to be
clear about what your purpose is in
defining the term human level error and
if it is to show that you can surpass a
single human and therefore argue for
deploying your system in some context
maybe this is the appropriate definition
but if you go is the proxy for Bayes
error then this is the appropriate
definition to see why this matters let's
look at an error analysis example let's
say for a medical imaging diagnosis
example then your training error is 5%
and your depth error is 6% and in the
example from the previous slide our
human level performance and I'm going to
think of this as proxy for Bayes error
depending on what
you defined it as a typical doctors
performance and experience after a team
of doctors you would have either one
percent or 0.7 percent or 0.5 percent
for this and remember also our
definitions from the previous video that
this gap between Bayes error or really
estimate laser and training error as
calling that a measure of the avoidable
bias and this as a measure an estimate
of how much of a variance problem you
have in a learning algorithm so in this
first example whichever of these choices
you make the measure of avoidable bias
will be something like 4% so be
somewhere between I guess 4% if you take
that to 4.5% if you use the 0.5% whereas
this is 1% so in this example I would
say it doesn't really matter which of
the definitions of human level ever you
use where did you use the typical
doctors error or the single experienced
doctors error or the team of experienced
doctors ever this whether this is a 4%
or 4.5% this is clearly bigger than the
variance problem and so in this case you
should focus on bias reduction
techniques such as training bigger
Network now let's look at a second
example let's say your training error is
1% and your dev error is 5% then again
it doesn't really matter since been
academic whether the human level
performance is 1 percent or 0.7 percent
or 0.5 percent because whichever of
these definitions you use your measure
of avoidable buyers will be I guess
somewhere between zero percent if you
use that to 0.5 percent right that's the
gap between the human level performance
in your training error whereas this gap
is 4 percent so this 4 percent is going
to be much bigger than the avoidable by
use either way and so you know this
suggests you could focus you should
focus on variance reduction techniques
such as regularization or getting a
bigger training setting but where it
really matters will be if doing training
error is 0.7 percent so you're doing
really well now and you're Jeff error is
0.8 percent
in this case it really matters that you
use USA for base error as 0.5% because
in this case your measure of how much
avoidable buyers you have is 0.2% which
is twice as big as your measure for your
own variance which is just 0.1% and so
this suggests that maybe both of the
bodies and their ins are both problems
but maybe the political bias is the
bigger of the problem and in this
example 0.5% as we discuss on the
previous slide was the best measure of
Bayes error because the team of human
doctors can achieve that performance so
if you use 0.7 as a proxy for base error
you would have estimates in the boydle
buyers as you know pretty much zero
percent and you might have missed that
you actually should try to do better
on your training set so I hope this
gives a sense also of why making
progress in machine learning problems
gets harder as you achieve well as you
approach children level performance in
this example once you've approached zero
point seven percent error unless it very
careful about estimating base error you
might not know how far away you are from
Bayes error and therefore how much you
should be trying to reduce avoidable
bias in fact of all you knew was that a
single typical doctor H is one percent
error and it might be very difficult to
know if you should be trying to fit your
training set even better and this
problem arose only when you're doing
very well on your problem already only
when you're doing you know point seven
percent point eight percent really close
to human level performance whereas in
the two examples on the left when you
are further away from human level
performance it was easier the table you
should focus on bias or variance so this
is a good illustration of why as you
approach human level performance is
actually harder to tease out the bias
and appearance effects and therefore why
progress on your machine learning
project just gets harder as you're doing
really well so just to summarize what
we've talked about if you're trying to
understand bias and variance where you
have an estimate of human level error
for a thought that humans can do quite
well you can use human level error as a
proxy
approximation for Bayes error and so the
difference between your estimate of
Bayes error tells you how much avoidable
bias is a problem
how much avoidable by it there is and
the difference in training error in dev
error that tells you how much variance
is a problem is whether your algorithms
able to generalize from the training set
to the DEF set and the big difference
between our discussion here and what we
saw in in earlier course was that
instead of comparing training error to
zero percent and just calling that the
estimates of the bias in contrast in
this video we're the more nuanced
analysis in which there is no particular
expectation that you should get zero
percent error because sometimes Bayes
error is nonzero and sometimes it's just
not possible for anything to do better
than a certain threshold of error and so
in the earlier course we're measuring
training error and see how much bigger
training error worse than zero and just
using that to try to understand how big
our biases and that turns out to work
just fine for problems where there is
error is nearly zero percent and if such
as recognizing cats humans are near
perfect for that so Bayes error is also
near perfect for that so that actually
works ok when Bayes error is nearly zero
but for problems where the data is noisy
like speech recognition on very noisy
audio when it's just impossible
sometimes to share what was said and to
get the correct transcription for
problems like that having a better
estimate for Bayes error can help you
better estimate avoidable bias and
variance and therefore make better
decisions on whether to focus on bias
reduction tactics or on variance
reduction tactics so to recap having an
estimate of human level performance
gives you an estimate of Bayes error and
does allows you to more quickly make
decisions as to whether you should focus
on try and reduce the bias or trying to
reduce the variance of your algorithm
and these techniques will tend to work
well until you surpass human level
performance whereupon you might no
longer have a good estimate of base
error that still helps you make this
decision really clearly now one of the
exciting developments in deep learning
has been that for more and more times
were actually able to surpass human
level performance in the next video
let's talk more about the process of
surpassing human level performance